everyone likes to say that bitcoin is
only used for criminals now that's an
absurd claim obviously but now we have a
lot of data before we look at how much
of bitcoin usage is actually for illicit
purposes it's important to understand
how much bitcoin usage is there in
general and so sam rule from bitcoin
magazine did a little analysis and they
tweeted out and said bitcoin has settled
over 60 trillion dollars in total
transfer volume and over 21 trillion
dollars in change adjusted volume in its
lifetime these are big big numbers 60
trillion dollars in total transfer
volume since the inception of bitcoin
now as you can tell from the chart there
has been a massive pickup around 2018
2019 and now all the way till today so
nearly 70 percent of total transfer of
volume has happened this year in 2021
that is pretty incredible so anyone who
says nobody uses bitcoin wrong we have
the data right here on top of that when
you start to look at the amount of
volume that is being done this year it
is starting to compete and become a
material percent of both mastercard visa
and other payment systems now bitcoin is
a decentralized digital payment system
you can send bitcoin but obviously
through things like strike as well you
can send dollars and other currencies as
well now the beauty of this is it's all
on chain there's a transparent ledger a
public ledger that we're able to analyze
and so if we go ahead and we do that the
these charts came from a tweet that
jameson law had which i thought was
really really powerful first the values
sent from north america to illicit
addresses illicit addresses include
everything from scams stolen funds dark
net markets fraud shops ransomware child
abuse material illicit actor
organizations and terrorism financing
that's an alphabet soup of every single
bad thing you could do on the internet
well if we go ahead and we look at that
dotted line that is the share of all
transfer value that is used for illicit
purposes it continues to fall lower and
lower and lower all the way back in july
of 2020 was estimated somewhere between
point six to point eight percent of all
transactions on the bitcoin network of
volume were for illicit purposes that
has fallen significantly all the way
down below 0.2 percent 20 basis points
of all transactions the bitcoin network
are going to things like scams stolen
funds dark net markets fraud shops
ransomware child abuse material illicit
actor organizations and terrorism
financing now if we go ahead and we look
not only at north america and we look at
eastern asia eastern asia is even
crazier at one point in july and august
of 2020 it was up around 1.5
all transactions for illicit value now
that is down again somewhere in that
kind of 0.1 to 0.2 percent so has fallen
significantly over the last remaining
months since july and august of last
year then if we go ahead and we look at
africa africa was even worse africa was
over three percent in july and august of
last year of illicit share of value but
that has fallen significantly as well
and it's fallen down somewhere in that
kind of 0.1 to 0.5
so across the world it doesn't matter
where you are there were high
percentages on a relative basis but that
has drastically fallen over the last 12
months or so unless kind of 15 months
now don't forget
the choice currency of criminals and
money launders and terrorists around the
world is still physical cash it's
untraceable anyone can use it and nobody
knows who owns it on top of that they're
able to launder money on a consistent
basis right through the very financial
organizations that say they're
preventing it
they literally go in and they money
launder whether it's mexican cartels or
other types of bad actors every single
bank comes under scrutiny because there
are billions of dollars that are
laundered through those organizations
there's estimations out of europe now
specifically i think it's the uk office
of drug control who continues to talk
about the fact that there are two
trillion dollars a year
laundered in fiat currencies two
trillion dollars just money laundering
not to speak of all the other illicit
activities
well that is
double the size of the entire bitcoin
market cap bitcoin is only a trillion
dollar asset two trillion dollars in the
fiat system whether you look at it on an
aggregate basis or on a percentage basis
bitcoin is not used anywhere near as
much for criminal activity as let's say
fiat currency why it's a transparent
ledger as i've said multiple times i
once talked to a law enforcement agent
and what he said to me was that a
federal law enforcement agent he
basically said
anytime somebody is committing a crime
we want their hands on a keyboard the
digital footprint is easy to track and
it's hard for them to hide or erase so
obviously if people are going to commit
crimes law enforcement and others would
love them to be using a transparent
ledger that anyone can evaluate so to
see these numbers isn't surprising
people are waking up to the fact that
maybe you shouldn't use a transparent
fully auditable verifiable payment
system to commit crimes are we surprised
by the numbers
i'm not surprised at all
i think the narrative used to be that
bitcoin was used for e-listed activities
back when like the silk road and stuff
was happening when people would order
illegal things on the internet but
obviously that narrative has shifted as
bitcoin has gone more mainstream um
people just stopped doing that so i'm
not surprised cash is definitely still
the number one
thing used by criminals for illicit
activities joe what do you think yeah
it's it's surprising that this narrative
still has stuck around right not only
has it been disproven from a number
standpoint all the charts that you just
went through it's a very very very small
percentage of uh kind of the transaction
volume that's going on not only that but
if you look at the legacy system that we
have today it's much much worse right
cash is one thing there's
exponentially more money being laundered
and being used for illicit activities
not only in cash uh but in electronic
money also and then you think about
simple things right things that are
actually legal overdraft fees
to 12 billion 12 and a half billion
dollars i think of overdraft fees last
year were taken by large u.s banks alone
so when you think about uh in the
context of like the total size of the
global economy and what's going on in
regular physical uh us dollar it's it's
uh not really much to talk about i don't
believe in the bitcoin space
the other piece of this that uh doesn't
get talked about a lot one is uh things
like um
uh whatever you wanna call uh uh uh
maybe not illicit activity but uh
definitely extracted value right is
maybe with the way to determine that uh
but another extracted value from legacy
system is inflation right that gets very
talked about a lot but one of the key
pieces to this is in many countries
these fiat currencies they have black
markets as well right so not only is it
used for illicit purposes but there's
people who operate in a gray area so for
example if you're in i don't know i'll
pick a country that somebody's told me
about before uh let's say that you're in
argentina and you want dollars right the
local currency is experiencing upwards
of 50
annual inflation so you probably don't
want to sit in that currency what you
would you like you'd like to go ahead
and get uh something like dollars right
there's stability to it the full faith
in credit the united states government
and so what you do is you try to go to
the black market and get it but at the
black market there's a couple of
challenges one is they mark it up right
so there's actually more expensive than
what the official exchange rate is two
is that it's dangerous there is
literally the ability if you show up
like imagine you show up with a duffel
bag full of physical cash and somebody
robs you what are you gonna do you're
gonna go to the uh police and say like
oh they robbed me over there at that uh
building maybe
probably not and so it's it's dangerous
both from a cost perspective but also
from like a little uh literal safety
perspective as well depending on what
country you're in how it works uh and so
i think that just naturally people are
gonna continue to uh move over use this
for good purposes because it's become
obvious that law enforcement knows how
to track it uh and i bet that the number
goes down over time rather than
continuing to kind of stay flat or go up
you know and return to where